We have a saying in asgard where there are
wolf's ears wolves teeth are near
it's a trap
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my brand new loki episode 6 trailer video
for the finale there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs a whole bunch of stuff they have to wrap up
and set up for loki season two because there will
be a season two if you guys didn't know they were
talking about last year but they've been pretty
quiet about it recently i think just because they
want to focus on the current episodes if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're going to be getting
marvel what if episodes after the loki finale and
i will be doing full episode videos for that so
i'll remind everyone at the end of the video too
but careful for spoilers for all the loki episodes
up to this point if you have not been watching the
series and there is a surprising amount of footage
from all these loki trailers that we can now say
is for sure from the finale i always wonder when
they release the promos and the trailers every
week how much of the season finale they include
in the earlier stuff it is always a surprise
how much of the later episodes make it into the
early stuff they did the exact same thing with
bigger shows like game of thrones on hbo for the
later seasons like you'd always get bits of the
finales early without really knowing that you were
watching part of the finale so the main storyline
though here heading into the finale is that loki
and silvie just defeated the lost smoke monster
just kidding defeating eliath who is kind of like
the loki series version of the lost smoke monster
and because of all the wizard of oz references
that other characters actually started making
during the episode i know i've been making a
lot of wizard of oz revealing the man behind the
curtain references but they actually literally
did it during this episode and they kind of
metaphorically pull back the eliath curtain when
they defeat him with the transition revealing
the citadel at the end of time if goliath weren't
actually devouring people whole like we actually
see him really killing people during the episode
i would have said that he was a total fake out
but if it wasn't clear though he was real he was
capable of killing people like he really did kill
classic loki in the sailors from the uss
eldridge and just like the comic book version
of his character he does eat all these alternate
timelines or most of these alternate timelines
when they do arrive in the void that's kind of
the point he acts as a trash compactor it seems
like he's also a creation or also serving whoever
is at the end of time here ravona renslayer also
on her way to this same place the same citadel
at the end of time using the information miss
minutes had on the creation of the tba and her
other secret files to find a way past the void
silly questioned her lies at the beginning of
episode 5 just asking if that prototype ship
she was hyping up was fake renslayer never really
answered her so it would be funny if they did pay
that off as like another kang easter egg having
her fly a version of something that looks kind of
like kang's timeship from the comics and just
addressing a lot of these kang the conqueror
easter eggs because people are talking about him
more and more there were a lot of references to
kang during episode 5 but i still feel like
the best the loki people like the producers
the writers will give us from kang in the finale
is some kind of post credit scene or some larger
easter eggs setting him up as a major threat but
i still feel like we're not going to actually see
jonathan major's kang in the flesh or at least
it seems like we won't see him in the flesh until
ant-man 3 quantomania they're just kind of using
the loki series to lay the groundwork like lay the
track work for why he's a big threat in the mcu i
think there was just a lot of evidence and scenes
during episode five meant to tell us that what
loki and sylvia are going to find her who they're
going to find inside that black castle is going to
be a big twist it's not going to be who everyone
wants it to be so you need to be really careful
about getting your hopes up about kang stuff in
the finale kang is kind of like the new mephisto
of the loki series it's probably not going to be
kang but it was cool seeing a version of the stark
tower like the avengers tower from an alternate
timeline that belonged to kang that's what the
q-e-n-g on the tower meant also pronounced kang is
the name of a company in modern day run by one of
the versions of kang from earlier in his timeline
the sphinx and the great pyramid are also kind
of kang easter eggs during kang's first big
marvel story he hijacked a version of dr doom's
time ship from the 20th century and disguised
it as the great sphinx using it to travel back to
ancient egypt to set himself up as rama tut ruling
as a pharaoh for a while until he left naming
apocalypse his successor but the joke was is that
the great sphinx was his time ship just made to
look like the great sphinx idious eliath the big
smoke monster had a big comic book connection
to immortus who is the oldest version of kang
from later in his timeline in immortus also had
a deep connection to the timekeepers and had his
own futuristic city called the chronopolis that
looked just like the tva but like i said i think
those are just meant to be easter eggs and that's
it the footage from the finale as you can see
is mostly just hyping up a version of kang loki
it'll be interesting to see what that scene winds
up being if it's a vision or if it's something
that's really happening or it's from an alternate
timeline then the hulls of the black citadel
itself loki walking through it just seems like
it's this cavernous place this is also meant to be
silvie you're seeing in the middle of a fight here
spinning around with her short sword her costume
just looks a little bit different a little darker
because there's barely any illumination inside
this great room inside the citadel like there's
a fireplace over here there's bookshelves in the
background a pedestal with a book on it it's just
like a living room for the person who's behind
all this what would you do if you literally had
all the time in the universe or the multiverse
so to speak doesn't it kind of remind you of the
inside of loki's cell from thor the dark world
with all the books that his mother had given him
the whole thing with the light at the top of the
tower the camera just keeps focusing on it during
sylvie's vision from goliath and then from the
ending scene it just seems like they're implying
that it's the source of this person's power where
they're broadcasting from so to speak controlling
everything from the actual end of time the way
they explain the timeline here too like the way
reality exists in this place per renslayer earlier
in the episode is that as we all suspected there
really is a multiverse like we all kind of thought
that even though the way they explained the sacred
timeline was a little confusing but that also
confirms why there can be so many variants of
loki of everyone running around who don't get
pruned but the actual end of time is meant to be
like this vanishing point of the multiverse where
all timelines from different universes converge
and literally vanish into oblivion like it just
ends it's like the heat death of the multiverse
the closest reference i could make to the way that
marvel tries to explain this in a scientific way
like an actual real-world scientific way is that
what happens after the heat death of the current
version of the multiverse is that another
big bang cycle happens in the next version
of the multiverse is born in a new timeline begins
like year zero and then everything happens again
in relatively similar order but slightly different
because it's a brand new timeline like the first
thing that happens is that a new version of
eternity is born with a completely different
personality from the previous one different
consciousness different goals then eternity
creates the celestials then the celestials start
experimenting with life all over the different
universes then so on so forth up to present day
where versions of all the characters that we know
come around but they're all slightly different
versions because it's a totally new timeline
but a lot of what's actually happening here in
this place at the end of time on the loki series
just depends on the way they explain why the
main villain did all this stuff with the tva the
keepers and why the person seemingly prunes more
loki's than any other person in the multiverse
i'll explain why i think that is in a second too
because it has to do with who the main villain is
i still love the theory that miss minutes is also
deeply connected to this because she's existed
since the creation of the tva so she would also
have to have been created by the person who's
behind all this so it sounds like she's more of
like a sub boss so to speak if you want to think
about her being evil and i'm trying to keep my
mind open about a couple of the wilder theories
about the final boss but i still feel like the
best one at least just given all the information
that they gave us during episode 5 is that the
person here at the end of time is meant to be
like the final boss form version of a loki we keep
making all the act of the hardness jokes it was
loki all along but if you really think about what
all the characters said during episode five and
remember that the series is only six episodes long
and the reveal is going to have to be a character
that we're already kind of familiar with like
the main villain will have to be a version of
someone that we've been watching this whole time
classic loki the other loki variants kept saying
that the reason why there were so many loki's
in the void more than any other type of person
is because all the other people the regular
people that got sent there even though the thor's
frog thor notwithstanding died almost immediately
were killed by eliath and as loki's their big
power move like what is common amongst all
versions of loki is that they are survivors
so who better to be the show's version of he who
remains the last living person in the multiverse
then yet another loki so if it's so easy for
loki's to just go camp out and do nothing by
themselves for a long long time then it feels like
they're trying to tell us that the final boss is
a version of loki who also just hatched a plan
to run to the end of time where he could control
all of time and the reason he did that will
probably wind up being some emotional callback
to something that our loki said earlier like
everything on the series is meant to connect
to what's been going on with r loki and his hero
redemption arc and that would also help explain
why so many loki's more than any other person
wind up getting pruned and sent to the void
because loki's more than any other person or sort
of like this big variable big unknown caused so
many problems in so many alternate timelines that
how do you get rid of those variables will you get
rid of them by sending them to the void whereas
the way they imply a lot of the other regular
marvel characters the big a-list characters
like the avengers are way more predictable
like if someone is going to mess up your sacred
timeline your grand plan is probably going to wind
up being a loki and who would know that better
than yet another loki loki seemingly know
themselves better than anyone else maybe we'll
get another joke about that whole love is a dagger
speech from episode three that was kind of funny
loki's stabbing each other in the back that was
also kind of a theme of episode 5 2 with president
loki and his men so who better to stab all loki's
across the multiverse across all timelines in the
back than yet another loki but there's still a ton
of other stuff that they have to wrap up in the
finale also set up loki season 2 and given how
evil renslayer came off in episode 5 she seems so
sinister now i wouldn't be surprised if she also
gets some sort of ending scene setting her up
as a bigger threat in the multiverse in the mcu
maybe if we're lucky something that also
foreshadows her eventual connection with
kang the conqueror i will talk about the future
of kang inside the mcu after the loki finale just
depending on what kind of other easter eggs and
foreshadowing we get so remember just keep your
expectations in check we're going to find out
what's going on pretty soon anyway my full loki
episode 6 video will post next wednesday just like
normal and then my marvel what if episodes will
start posting in august just like normal there's
also a really cool loki deleted scenes video that
i'll post tomorrow they just revealed a bunch of
really cool frog thor deleted scenes involving
chris hemsworth so make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss any of those videos
congratulations miguel martinez you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my full loki episode 5 video and click
here for my full marvel what if trailer video
and easter eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!